good morning Hank it's Monday oh God I
feel a change coming on oh yeah there
has been an alteration and not for the
better I thought if I let it grow longer
this year it might look better but no it
looks like it does every year it's Pizza
miss everybody the most magical time of
the year where Hank and I make videos
every weekday for two weeks like it's
2007 all over again and sell weird stuff
with my mustache on it at pizzamist.com
for charity this box right here contains
all the 2022 Pizza stuff I haven't seen
any of it we'll start off with the
shirts oh my gosh it's Pizza John the
baseball jersey look at all look at all
those Baseball playing
mustachioed maze so they seem to only
have sent me small t-shirts possibly to
force me to buy my own merch at
pizzamist.com so I'm gonna have my kids
model it's hard to pick a favorite one
but I think it might be the one with the
bat or the the ginger me all right what
do we have next oh no it's Shrek Sir
John it's hard to pronounce beautiful to
wear I don't know if I even like Shrek
but I love the internet loving Shrek
also oh my God if it rides I lives from
my low quality series cars versus the
car even has a mustache how has all of
this magic even happened by the way all
of this is available only during this
year's pizza miss.com and all the
proceeds go to support stronger
Healthcare Systems in Sierra Leone we
could not possibly keep profit from this
madness this might be one of my
favorites ever it's wondrous they're
also good they're not like pizza miss
good they're good except for the Shrek
one that one's Pizza it's good couple
more t-shirts this year beginning with
this one which is me and a pizza box I
just love it I've always wanted to have
a square head and last but certainly not
least for the t-shirts we have it's a
pizza rainbow John okay we've also got
lots of other stuff we've got pizza Miss
fridge magnets Pizza Miss stickers
featuring all this year's designs and
also Pizza Miss car air freshener which
is new John smell let's take a Sniff and
see what new Jon Snow is all about it's
got some clove some garlic maybe on the
end it smells as much like pizza or meat
as you would want your car to smell we
got a high quality Pizza John water
bottle so you can stay hydrated while
remembering the magic of pizza Miss okay
while my faceless Winters continue to
model in the background I gotta look up
the other stuff that's not in my box
that I got an email about but I didn't
open it because I didn't want to be
spoiled okay we have two more pieces of
apparel that are just phenomenal number
one this pizza John cardigan wow wow and
number two a pizza John soccer jersey or
football jersey depending on your world
view both home and away are available
white and red they are are phenomenal
thank you to our friends at Adidas and
no matter what your last name is your
last name is pizza okay what else how
about a set of pizza John hand towels
you heard me right and if that's not
enough for you how about a pizza John
floor rug that is big enough for eight
cats unfortunately almost all these
items are limited edition so only
available while supplies last including
this beautiful screen print of one of my
all-time favorite pizza John designs La
Pizza Mort signed by both me and the
artist have I saved the best for last
maybe we've got a pizza John
neoclassical bust I don't even know what
to say about it except of course if it
was an actual Greek or Roman bust it
would have been painted you you can
paint yours it's up to you also we got a
pizza John pin subscription just like we
did last year so pins come every month
for six months so you can celebrate
Pizza Miss for half a year there's also
Pizza John washi tape and other stuff
only available at pizzamous.com for the
next two weeks oh my God I love pizza
Miss every year but I might love it this
year the most tank it's time to say my
all-time favorite sentence I will see
you tomorrow I gotta get out of her
light and let her Let Her Shine hold on
I gotta get that focused right are you
not enjoying this I am this is what
vegan influencer is all about Alice yeah
do you think I want to do you get the
joke yeah yes I get the joke
that looks like SpongeBob he does a
little bit Happy Pizza Miss
pizzas.com 100 of the profits go to
support stronger Healthcare Systems in
Sierra Leone